hello everyone welcome back to the
supper suite at Austin South by
Southwest we are covering a whole ton of
movies here thanks to our fine friends
right now we are gonna give a quick plug
to hint water because we are so so
thankful for hint water because now we
get to talk about a movie like miss
white light which I'll just tell you
guys right off the bat I absolutely
loved I already said it to you all and I
genuinely mean it this one really kind
of kind of caught me and I was surprised
because usually when it comes to subject
matter like this I get super sensitive
and this kind of left me in a hole full
place so I really appreciate that um
let's start with you Paul where exactly
did this idea come from do professions
like this really exist and as that what
inspired it um this initially came from
being with my dad he was dying and it
just was on my mind quite a bit so I
wanted to explore this the subject
matter as far as this profession
existing I I made it up but I there's
weird little pockets of there is a death
industry and so there are people that
don't officially work for hospice that
do like I've heard the term death doula
that's an actual thing that I've
carson's an actual doula
but yeah leave that the the more joyful
version of a doula but there is a I've
heard of I've heard the term death doula
there are people that kind of tinker but
not this you know they're not people in
strip malls with like quasi failing
businesses trying to do this oh now I'm
really curious given the fact that you
are an actual doula do you see any
similarities between how it's handled
here and what you do absolutely um yeah
being a I think the word doula is used
for birth and death and we actually call
it full spectrum doula because it's the
same job just different same passageway
same job different times of people's
lives I think it's just the power of
listening to someone holding their hand
not having your own emotional stake in
the game for birth and
but really just being there as an
advocate and a year I think they're
exactly the same
that's so wildly impressive because
there's an overly emotional person I
can't imagine taking that out of the
equation overly emotional and overly
anxious person so I feel like then in a
way I was gravitated towards this job to
help me do that and to put me in a place
where I had to be strong for somebody
else very important thing to have in
this world Roberta I'm dying to know
about how you joined here because really
this is one of my favorite performances
of the entire festival I love what you
did here so what drew you to this
particular role and is there anything
kind of Paul helped you with that
brought something out of you that you
didn't even know you were capable of
before yeah I I read the script my agent
kind of sent me the script and I I read
it and I I loved it and and it was after
I met Paul and then we had a
conversation on the phone when I was my
friend's house in Long Island and I was
I really wanted to do the movie and I
wanted to talk to Paul about where he
was coming from when he wrote it and
like what you know what do you kind of
expected out ILECs because you know you
go into auditions sometimes all you know
is that what's in the script and you
don't have a background for you don't
have like the the conversation with the
director before you go in an audition so
once you know once we got to talking
about it I was just like yeah this is
this is a really cool different
vulnerability that I've never really
touched in my career so far and and I I
was really I was really happy to do it I
mean like I don't I don't get to play
characters like this very often so you
don't see characters like this very very
very refreshing in the movie it's
brought up pretty often where people are
asking about like what do you really do
and it's never defined as in a bullet
point list so I was just curious just
for you getting into that headspace is
that something the two of you had to
work out yourself I mean there there is
a certain hesitancy that she has about
answering anything about herself and so
I didn't I I'm not like I'm a method
actor or anything like that but I was
just like I'm not gonna question all
these choices I'm not gonna go there
like it almost felt like if I if I
question too much about her I would be
doing it without her consent
like she would want the privacy of just
like to just like you know you know and
III but the conversations that I had
with Paul were really illuminating as
far as like where he came from when he
was writing it and so like if I just
wanted to pay attention to that and and
be there for that
another big standout element to the
movie is the father/daughter
relationship I understand that they have
to work on things they're in too much of
a routine but there was something about
just the comfort of that whole thing
that I really took - so can you tell me
a little bit about just prepping for the
movie for the two of you because I
imagine it's a little challenging to
just jump into a shoot and be able to
have so much family history kind of
radiated off screen like that yeah yeah
and it's to me it was everything the
relationship from my perspective and so
I really wanted to meet Roberta and we
met at some diner in the West Village
and you're right she was not really
gung-ho about answering too many
questions and I on the other hand was
like so what do you think and when and
so so how long do you think and why are
we in Indiana it is you know how it is I
was like yeah yeah yeah but you know
maybe we should I was just really
excited about about tackling those
questions but more importantly just like
broadly the father-daughter relationship
at at that age you know like a
middle-aged man and and then the young
adult daughter you know you know IIIi
grew up in the single with a single mom
you know and like didn't have the dad
you know so I really was looking forward
to visiting some of those dreams of mine
you know in this relationship you know
and and yes they have problems but I
love the consistency and
the loyalty and the commitment that that
is there for him and yeah I'm in that
place with my father right now where we
there's so much now he's in his 70s and
I'm you know my age and like it's just
you know there are things that we've
never talked about and now I'm like how
do I even bring this up like when like
we're you know because we've never had
those conversations and I and I love
that about this relationship and playing
this relationship is it like yeah like
you realize at some point years and
years later that you don't know stuff
about people that you're the closest
with and you don't even know how to
bring it up I am well aware of that
given the fact that I meant like right
the same point in life with with my
father so it's a it's definitely a
really touching thing to see on screen
and Judith we were talking about this
before you're having quite the year
right now because you know how much I
loved before you know it yeah how is the
the festival circuit life treating you
right now or you are you like exhausted
from all the traveling no no not at all
I mean I get to be with these folk and
and that's really a joy for me and to
see that this film is getting the kind
of attention that I really believe that
it deserves in minoo we can all talk
about how tired we are and you know
those are those are those are real
problems you know these problems it was
just so exhausting no I don't they don't
go there
this is a thrilling time and a thrilling
time in my life my career and I just
wanted to say something to the two of
you are it's just listening to your
nights thinking you know there's this
thing about how we think our career is
the whole container for everything in in
lots of ways but it's our lives that get
affected so it's the life that's a
container and all the content of the
different parts that we play and
different things that we do brings up
things in our lives that are waking us
up to things that we hadn't talked about
before like you were talking about being
a doula and you know Paul is talking
about dealing with his father's death
and you're talking about your
relationship with your father and
you're coming to grips with you're
relating to not having had a father and
there's something about working on a
project that is as substantive and as
deep and is rooted in relating as this
project is that I think takes us all up
to a whole other level in our lives and
I think that's what this is this is for
that's what we do this for that's why I
love filmmaking and storytelling that's
what I mean that's the storytelling that
leads us into something and then all of
a sudden we wake up and we say oh wow I
didn't deal with my father I didn't deal
with my father not that you didn't deal
with it but it wakes us up to something
else that's very rich and and and
vibrant for for all of us so another
thing I wanted to ask you about because
I know before you know it takes place in
New York and I just heard Long Island
and I love the New York film community
yes sadly I had to move from New York to
LA even though I love LA New York is
always at my heart so I was just
wondering if you could speak a little
bit to kind of the community there
because we're clearly even though the
businesses is in LA we are clearly
getting a whole bunch of great projects
in New York Oh New York is there's no
question about it I mean it's really
become a film and television Mecca at
this point and I know a lot of projects
that I'm talking about right now we're
gonna be doing in New York and so it's
not like all of a sudden and I happen to
be I mean I'm a Jersey girl and I'm a
New Yorker and my husband loves LA and
you can love LA and that's great but
there's also another part and I just
finished a great project in LA I like it
I Love New York and to see this
happening in New York but also I would
speak to the fact that Indiana and Zack
and Paul and Gordon strain and Mark I
mean they're all doing this film create
this community in Indiana that's
demonstrating and inspiring other people
to know that you can do this kind of
film work on this great film work in
your community and in this particular
case we shot in Bloomington Indiana no
it's just it was a it was a thrill I
mean I thought Indiana really and I got
there and ever but that's your that
should be your tag right or your t-shirt
Indiana really
that's what everyone says it's really
it's important it's really important to
speak to that as we speak about New York
and LA and right here in the middle of
the country we have this place that is
booming
do you want to say that I did read a
couple years ago that in New York there
is now we've kind of we've switched tied
said New York has more television and
film production in the last five years
and then LA and that's partly because
Bloomberg who was genius in giving the
tax break when we shot Ugly Betty there
we saved a half a million dollars on
every single show every week
I mean that he really made a difference
you can't you can't beat that
absolutely tax incentives are there yeah
hopefully we get a tax incentive in
Indiana that happens just watch out
about the community there and how that
started cuz I know you two have worked
together before also yeah yeah yeah well
I was an undergrad at Indiana University
when Paul was a grad student there and
he wrote the very first plays that I
ever acted him so we've known each other
ten years how old do you think you are
I'm much older than that yeah so for a
really long time we did our first movie
our big is his first film the good
Catholic we did that together back in
Bloomington and since then we've been
trying to build this groundswell of of
films that you don't expect to come out
of the Midwest like when I was growing
up in Indiana the only movies to come
out of Indiana were about white guys
achieving it sports you know like
Hoosiers Rudy Breaking Away they're all
great films and they're some of my
favorite movies we didn't see movies
like this and the diversity of story
that's being able to take place in
stories like that in Indiana and so
that's something we're focusing on we
want to tell different types of stories
in places that you don't expect and and
reach new audiences with those stories
because we come from the New York
backgrounds so we've got the roots of
New York theater and being able to see
the
different people that you're able to
touch with the theater in New York I
mean that's what we're we're trying to
take that and bring it into the middle
of the Midwest it's so important to do
especially being somewhere like Austin
right now I love the community here and
I love how this festival also highlights
movies with Austin in it so to see that
in all different areas of the country is
super exciting I think I have to wrap
this up soon I have a million more
questions but to conclude I just wanted
to ask you guys what in this movie kind
of stuck with you the most there are so
many different things and like I said at
the very beginning the feeling that I
walked away with was probably the
biggest takeaway but the one scene that
I don't think I'm ever gonna shake is
the pizza conversation just this idea of
you not being able to enjoy something
you want to enjoy but being able to
enjoy it through somebody else so like
that was kind of the one big thing for
me but I was curious what what you guys
are gonna take with you from this
experience this is a big one I mean on
my end I have this thing for so long
I've been living with this for a very
long time and honestly the thing that I
really love about it and I'm realizing
it now because I've not seen these
people together in the same room until
today because there's there's fragmented
scenes and they're not all in scenes
together and to see everybody here and
realize I thought they were all like
when I watched the movie it feels like
they were all working in unison
as one unit and and seeing them now
together and in real life in the room
for the first time it that's kind of
what hit me that like wow these people
were so good at their job then I assume
that they all knew each other for the
last two years
well you're our driving connection and
so that really makes a huge difference
we also know that in your choice of
casting you also choose people not only
for what they are able to do in terms of
their craft
but also who they are as human beings
and that's your grand intuition I would
say for me it's about how do we how do
we live since we know we're going to die
how are we going to live Oh feel like
it's a testament to the strength of the
movie that I interpreted that as a
positive thing but there's no question
about it yeah I think the what stuck
with me is the ability that we rely on
on ourselves but also connection and
other people to help us realize how we
want to live and how a single encounter
can shift the whole course of one's life
I think is powerful any last-minute
additions before I get kicked off the
stage I'll just say that the as
fragmented as the stories within the
story are with the characters and how
isolated they seem and alone the the the
thing that I'm left with is is is is the
overcoming of that for the sake of
connection and to live but to live
boldly and this grip does that when you
read it it's just like a bold ass script
it's like pages of dialogue monologues
and it's like wow don't see that it's
like and there's a and and and and and
there's something refreshing about that
not only as an actor to take that on but
I think it's an extension of how I want
to be left with with how I choose to
live my life which is in this bold
manner I think I have to wrap this up
sadly thank you so much for watching
this interview right now a huge thanks
to all you guys for being here again and
miss white light please keep an eye out
for it it is a great movie
right here from the supper suite in
Austin thanks for watching this we will
see you soon with more South by
Southwest interviews
[Applause]
you